les astronautes vous souhaitent la bienvenue les amis
Roskosmos Anton Shkalera et Petr Dubrov
de l'espace international
les stations passent les derniers instants
sortant 2021 nous sur l'ISS et vous sur
la terre blâme à nouveau le sentiment magique
Vacances du Nouvel An pour beaucoup
est sur le point de commencer à la table du Nouvel An
tous les amis proches de la famille se réuniront, nous
nos collègues astronautes aussi
très bientôt nous nous réunirons pour improviser sur
Table du nouvel an
sommes devenus nous serons pour de vrai
Nouvel An mais seulement sans champagne oui
à la station dry law mais le reste
conditions dont le menu nous avons le maximum
près du sol, ce qui est particulièrement agréable
en un tel jour férié
amis heures restantes nous vous voulons
tout le monde a réussi à se plonger dans cette magie
humeur du nouvel an et a dit
félicitations chaleureuses à ceux qui attendent
nous et vous souhaitons une bonne année 2022
santé endurance bien-être et nouveau
réalisations être amical heureux avec
Nouvelle année